[Music]
Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
>> Are you sure you want to do this?
>> I have no choice.
Why don't we have a choice? Everybody
has a choice.
>> Yes, you have it. But unless it's an uh
requirement,
>> you mean it has to fit in with the
common good.
>> I don't know what's common about this.
Maybe it's and it's not even good
probably.
>> All right.
>> Well, we're going to
>> Don't ask me how I am.
>> I won't.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. So, we can skip that once again.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm okay.
No.
>> Well, you're trying to make me jealous
or what?
>> I think before we start anything, let's
just pray.
>> If we don't do that, I don't know.
>> Then we're in big trouble.
>> Okay, let's pray.
Our heavenly father, thank you once
again for bringing us together. Thank
you for all the blessings that you give
us. We ask that you again enlighten our
minds with the Holy Spirit that we can
bring this discussion as you would like
it to be in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Martin, what is this interesting
first slide here?
Uh, is this Tesla inspired?
>> Well, it's probably part of this.
>> So, you have a power source, a global
power source. What is that coat of arms
hanging there between them?
>> It's where the power source comes from.
>> I see. Are those the keys that open
the nether world and the heavenly
realms?
>> It's
>> I wonder who holds them. The one with
the triple crown.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> And I see that there are various
countries there that are plugged into
the power source, namely
the United States of America.
And then you have the Russians and you
have the Chinese and you have the
Europeans.
Now, where's the rest? They probably
fall under the bricks. They probably
fall under that second power
source there, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. So, everybody's basically there.
>> Everybody.
>> And people always go and look for the
problem
>> elsewhere
>> either in one of the countries.
>> Yeah. But that just pawns in a game.
Yeah.
>> If they're not plugged into that power
source,
then they don't understand the
ramifications of history. That's why you
have a lot of people that are out there
on social media. They've got certain
portions, right? But when it comes to
the
>> crux of the matter,
>> like you said, the man behind the mask,
>> do you for one moment think
that a power that held sway politically,
religiously
for millennia
>> is just going to relinquish and become a
whimpering little
uh
whatever. No,
>> if you read your Bible and you know who
sits behind all of this,
>> yes,
>> then no, that won't happen because if
the dragon is behind all of it,
>> if you look at the old history and you
look at even all the movies, I mean,
take a simple thing like u the three
musketeers.
You had the musketeers that were on the
side of the king
and then you had the musketeers that
were on the side of the papal leates,
right?
>> The cardinal
>> and apparently they were always fighting
each other. But that was just for the
public eye because behind the scenes
they were all in cahoots, right?
>> Mhm.
>> And the one was subject to the other.
And if you take the powers of Europe
and the battles that took place for the
supremacy, physical battles
such as the 30-year war, for example,
>> or the battles of the Reformation
and how Protestantism and Catholicism
were, you know, at loggerheads
and then the battle in the United
Kingdom OM for example,
and you had the ascendancy of
Protestantism.
>> But it was never pure Protestantism.
>> It was always religopolitical
Protestantism.
>> There always had to be a king that
ruled, an earthly
representative. Isn't that right?
>> Yeah. So in England, they made it the
king or the queen, whoever sat on the
throne, whoever placed her or his
posterior on that so-called stone.
>> Mhm.
>> That was the resting place for Jacob's
head. If you want to believe such dril,
>> I don't.
>> But they even fight wars over the stone,
whether it should be in Scotland or
whether it should be elsewhere.
And then eventually you had uh the
counterreformation
and you had the Oxford movement
>> and there was this constant sway between
Protestantism and Catholicism.
And in between the religious systems
were basically eradicated or replaced
with something as ridiculous
as a church state parade
>> that was either masonic or military but
anything other than Christian.
>> Can I sum it up like that?
>> Yeah.
>> And then from there all the strings has
been
>> pulled. Countries have been put where
they want them.
>> Yes. I can think of Israel for instance.
>> Imagine walking into St. Paul's
Cathedral
>> and stepping onto the black and white
Masonic squares,
looking up to the ceiling and seeing the
compass and the set square and seeing
the allseeing eye looking down upon you
and imagining that you're in a Christian
conclave
>> when masonry rules that officially,
according to its documents, worships
Lucifer as the as the true son of God.
Then Martin, what is Christian about
that? It's a ruse.
>> Only the word Christian. And then you go
to the Vatican
and you see the representative of Rome
sitting on a great white throne with two
cherubs and four living creatures,
namely ranking papal representatives
sitting around him pretending that the
man on the throne is God on earth and
his documentation says the same and then
they call it Christian.
>> Martin, it's pathetic. It's an
abomination.
>> It's an abomination.
And then you have Protestants
>> Mhm.
>> divided up into thousands of factions
eventually
relinquishing the cornerstones of their
doctrines. righteousness by faith
>> and faith alone. That beautiful word
alone over which millions were
slaughtered
because the system has to save you and
not Christ
>> and then them giving up their faith,
throwing their arms into the air,
joining ecumenical movements, signing
charter ecuomanicas,
claiming that the pope is the
representative. Yeah,
>> it's disgusting.
>> But isn't it um done in love?
>> Well, I don't know whether it's done in
love. If Candace Owen, who has become a
Catholic, says that, you know, if you
have half a brain, you can't be a
Protestant.
Uh the reason for that is that there is
no Protestant left.
>> That's true. I wanted to ask, do you
think she really knows the history, the
true history, not the the Catholic
version of history? No, I don't think
any of them know. So Martin, this power
source, can we really assume that this
war, this conflict
that has been raging
over all these centuries, that this
conflict is coming to a boiling point
and where the power, the global power
is ready to stake its claim as the moral
representative of deity on earth.
>> Do you think it's happening?
>> I think it's happening, but I don't
think people will be
grasping or seeing it.
>> All right.
>> Because it's still in it's still behind
the scenes that he's doing it.
>> Now, over the years,
I have been branded as a conspiracy
theorist.
>> Thank you. I've also now been that
>> Have you been indoctrinated? Yes. You
poor man. Please use your own brain.
Now the interesting thing is that the
the largest uh accusations or the
greatest volume of accusations didn't
necessarily come from without.
>> Many without embraced it.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> It came from within.
And I wonder where these so-called
anti-conspiracist
people
that claim that all these things are a
conspiracy and for that matter the
entire Bible is then a conspiracy.
>> Mhm. Which started in Eden and is
culminating in our days that this
conspiracy as written in the book of
Revelation couched in signs and symbols.
And doesn't masonry do the same?
>> Yes.
>> Couches its uh conspiracies in signs and
symbols and funny little handshakes and
little hand signs and uh uh the satanic
symbols in the most strange environments
even to this very day.
>> Mhm.
Uh I find it fascinating
that uh after the initial proclamation
of this uh conspiracy
between good and evil
that uh the world took it up
and we had to say nothing about it
anymore because the world was saying it.
They're screaming it from every channel.
I I watch their videos Martin as they
come out one after the other and I
recognize some of the slides that they
are using.
>> Yes,
>> I see it as well.
>> Can you see it sometimes? You know,
suddenly there's a a demographic that is
being displayed there and I recognize
that slide.
It comes out of the total onslaught
series many many years ago.
>> And that which was conspiracy
>> is now no longer branded as
dubious
>> but as mainstream.
>> Yeah.
>> No, that's true. I mean if I can just
take in the last 10 years how many
because that's when I watched Total
Onslaught for the first time. How many
of the things that was said there has
now come to fruition?
>> It's just it's just common knowledge.
And I wonder where all those um
voluous
high decibel individuals that opposed it
where they are now
>> because I don't have to quote Total
Onslaught at all. I can pick up Dash
Spiegel
>> and read Total Onslaught in it.
>> Yeah. In the latest ones.
>> In the latest ones. We'll see in a
moment.
>> And I And I I just am so grateful that
sooner or later, as they say, what goes
wrong comes wrong. M
>> if truth
is truth
>> no matter how much it is covered in lies
and deception
eventually
it will come to the four
>> it will
>> doesn't the Bible say that Jesus Christ
is full of grace and truth
>> and everlasting
>> now if if You go into one of these
churches today
where they claim that they are preaching
truth and you're standing on black and
white squares with Masonic symbols
beaming over your head
or you're sitting in some prosperity
class where you're told that if you open
your wild mouth wide enough you will get
gold fillings.
Uh does that rhyme with uh the truth
that is proclaimed under the
bloodstained banner of Prince Emmanuel?
>> No, not at all.
>> So Martin,
when the Bible says in John
that the word became flesh
and we beheld his glory. That's his
character.
The glory of the only begotten
son of the father
full of grace
>> but begotten truth not as created but as
unique
>> one of the kind one of a kind who was
before
>> anything was made because without him
was not anything made that was made.
Martin, this truth, this sublime truth
is so trampled by this power that
perceives itself as the global power.
But before we we wax too eloquently on
this issue,
uh let us look at a few statements here
and a few events that have taken place
where it comes to the point where after
this conflict
between the righteousness of Christ,
let's take it down to its basics, the
righteousness of Christ and
justification. by faith and faith alone
the cornerstone of Protestantism,
the cornerstone of the word of God.
Right?
So Martin having in their opinion
successfully swept away
this cornerstone of Protestantism
>> and reinstated themselves as the source
of power
>> and deity on this earth.
We have come to the full circle. They
wielded the power in the middle ages.
They apparently relinquished it
>> but went underground
then reasserted themselves and in the
present millure are ready to take that
power back
>> and they will get their lackey the one
on the left over there to publicly do it
for them.
>> Yeah. and the others will follow suit
because uh without it they are cut off
from human existence. And in any case,
communism was started by the Jesuits in
their reductions
in South America,
uh, perfected and introduced via their
papal knights, whether they were called
Lenon or whether they were called marks
or whether they were called whatever
they were,
and implement it. and the others, those
of the European Union, still have all
their laws in place. They haven't been
relinquished. They have just been laid
to rest for a little while and then
until they can be reactivated.
>> So, let's have a look at a few videos
and see where we are standing in the
stream of this time.
>> Madagascar has extended a ninetime
curfew in the capital, Antonivo, and
four other cities. Residents are taking
stock of the damage after a day of
protests that left several people dead.
On Thursday, thousands of mostly young
people answered social media calls to
demonstrate against frequent power cuts
and water shortages on the island that's
located off the southeastern coast of
Africa. There were widespread looting
and attacks on shopping centers and
several people lost their lives. And um
members of Generation Zed have called
for the movement to continue. Um what's
interesting in this movement, it's new.
Uh I've never seen that in 15 years. Uh
it's mostly students, very young people.
So that's why they call they call their
movement Gen Z movement.
>> Um and there's no I haven't seen any
political leader behind it. I haven't
seen any uh political um uh using of
this. So it was mainly young people. Uh
but the the the tricky uh part of this
uh movement is that uh at the end of the
protest at the end of the day on
Thursday um protesters got more and more
violent and it was a it looked like it
was a different population. Um because
the Jenzi movement said they were a
peaceful movement. They didn't want any
violence. They don't want to do a a
pooch, a coup. They said they just
wanted uh to be heard.
>> Martin, as we discussed in our last one,
>> the youth has to be mobilized.
>> Definitely. That's
been the history of the world.
>> Yes. So if you want riots on the
streets,
>> Mhm.
>> it's very hard to get the 70 year olds
and the 80 year olds to be mobilized
into that kind of activity.
It's going to take a while.
>> You have to use the youth.
>> And so we discussed last time that's why
masonry has the demol this massive youth
movement. The French revolution was
powered by the youth. The hippie
movement bringing in the new morality
was powered by the youth. And of course
you use uh the harp, the sitter, the
doulamer, the guitar, the electric
guitar, the bass guitar, the drums. I'm
just paraphrasing Daniel
>> chapter 3.
And uh rile up the spirit, put them into
an an alpha zone so that their cognitive
function is impaired while they climb
onto barricades. Maybe people can now
understand why there are always when
there's a protest music the whole time
with it.
>> Yes. And uh normally behind all of these
movements whether it was the French
Revolution
whether it was the hippie movement
whether it was wherever
the Jesuits were involved.
>> Let's make it quite plain. Whether it
was the Nazi movement with the Hitler
youth
>> didn't he say I see Himla as my ignazius
of
>> Lyola
>> didn't he invoke the Jesuit
uh philosophy of fascism
>> there's a lot of talk about fascism but
the fasi are everywhere in the
>> capital
>> and uh from Lincoln sitting on his chair
with the capital
or with the fasi on either side. That is
just their system of government where
the industry is linked.
>> Yeah.
>> The the the rich mega moguls are linked
in with the economy so that they can
drive the processes and programs they
want without necessarily being trapped
in party ideology. So we can actually on
this picture have a lot more plugins,
not only countries, you can have the
industry.
>> Oh, you can have them all. You can have
the merchants of the world plugged in
over there with their signed
>> documents that they signed with Pope
Francis or Rum Novarum from the previous
Pope Leo and the present Pope Leo.
They're all linked in there. and the
labor movements
>> and uh the Christian ecumenical
movements, you can all plug them there
into that power source. You either plug
in there
>> or you run out of power, Martin.
>> Yeah. I mean, if you take that young
African leader Tore,
what got him so popular? It's they don't
know how it happened.
>> It just happened. But it's again this
this behind the scenes and using social
media riing all of this up.
>> So who is
behind generation Z? That is the
question.
>> What is the source of power?
>> But I love this word power. May I
digress for a moment?
>> Yeah.
>> Into the religious realm.
>> We can
>> of course.
>> Okay. because they link everything back
eventually to to religion
>> and this is what it will be about. Of
course, we have to get prophecy and
religion back.
>> You know, I I just love John chapter
one. It's such a powerful testimony of
who Christ is, right?
And uh the verse where it says in John
chapter one, he came unto his own and
his own received him not.
But then it says, but oh, I love this
word but in the Bible. If it weren't for
the but we'd all be lost, right?
But
to as many as received him, he gave
power
>> to become the sons of God.
So Martin, I want to know what that
power is.
>> Yes. Because that's also misconstrued.
>> Yes. So do I want to be with that power
or do I want to be with this global
power under papal enzyme?
Well, what is that power? Well, if you
read a little bit further and you skip
the gospels and you go to Acts,
then you will read that they were told
to t in Jerusalem
and they will receive power.
>> Ah,
and that power was the Holy Spirit.
>> Mhm.
>> Now, the power of the Holy Spirit that
they were to receive, that's the real
power source that you have to be plugged
into, by the way, and not this one
that's on our screen over here.
Then Martin, the power is one that
convicts you of the role of the son of
God in salvation.
Because that power that you will
receive, the outpouring of the Holy
Spirit will firstly convict you of sin
and righteousness and judgment.
>> And in other words, it'll lead you to a
heart conversion.
And it will testify of Christ, the
centrality of Christ in salvation and
not systems that are plugged into an
earthly power that according to the
scripture will be destroyed by the
brightness of Christ's coming.
>> Can I can I speak like that without
getting into trouble?
>> Well, it's biblical.
>> But I have a question.
>> Yes. the power of the Holy Spirit.
There can also be a false one.
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> So,
>> yeah, getting those gold teeth jumping
up and down, rolling on the ground. It's
all very nonproductive
except that the emotions are riled up
and maybe generation Z can go and uh
build some barricades and throw some
fiery cocktails.
>> That's the problem. So we have to make
sure that the power through the from the
Holy Spirit
>> yes
>> is biblical.
>> Yes.
>> Now let me make it quite plain. I'm not
rejecting or denigrating generation Z
>> because Christ didn't
>> neglect the younger generation. All his
disciples came out of that generation.
>> He needed that oomph.
>> Of course the remnant movement the same.
But they couldn't work without the power
source of the Holy Spirit to direct
their thoughts and actions.
Uh if the power source becomes the
Jesuits,
>> well, didn't that professor at uh
Georgetown University, wasn't he behind
the flyers that said, you know, catch
this bullet, etc., etc.
Wherever you go in this rabbit hole, you
will find a Jesuit sitting there
somewhere.
>> Definitely always.
>> All right. So that's the point with
generation Z. You have marshaled the
energy. M
>> now you have to project this bullet that
you have created this whole generation
and push it in the right direction
according to them
>> and I in my opinion it's pushing them
over the precipice
>> because if we see this and where it's
going to lead you're going to have them
bring religion in it especially in the
US and like we'll also see the Charlie
Kirk thing and what it's com um brought
up out of the woodworks.
>> Well, let's continue. Let's look at the
next one. So, it's not only Madagascar,
Martin, it's Morocco, it's South Africa
>> and we showed in the previous one the uh
Nepal, Sri Lanka, how many has been
>> everywhere all over the world, England,
right?
>> Mhm. So youthled protests are roing
countries in disparate parts of Africa
from the Indian Ocean to the Sahara with
members of so-called generation Z. Those
under 28 years old taking to the streets
in frustration over years of poor
governance.
And as we have said they're overrunning
the king of the south. So the poor
governance is all attached to the left.
Now, it's interesting to me that if I
read some of the comments on our own
discussions,
the people are concerned that it seems
as though we are aligning ourselves more
with the right than with the left.
Right. But I think we've made it
abundantly clear that we align ourselves
with neither.
>> No. And if there are elements in the
right that are biblical then obviously
we will be aligning with it but it's
aligning with the Bible not with their
philosophy.
>> Correct. And there are elements in the
left where we definitely align ourselves
with the left
>> where there has to be this separation
because it's a question of moral choice
that cannot be legislated. The left has
excellent points
>> when it comes to that. Yes.
>> Yes. The right has excellent points when
it comes to what's right and wrong, but
when it comes to the implementation,
the danger is going to come from the
right.
>> And we've been saying this from episode
one, we don't choose sides. We look at
it from a biblical perspective.
>> So don't put us in a category. The only
category we want to fit in is the
biblical one. So we have the generation
that can power the process and it has
become a militant
>> generation willing to use violence to
bring about change. Yeah.
>> Isn't that happened in the French
Revolution?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
Then Trump's F-35 deal with Ardugan
spells danger for Israel. Really? I mean
there will be some people that will be
>> overjoyed now because now Turkey is
going to play its role in the Middle
East and not only overrun Israel but
then according to their philosophy they
must overrun their their partner Egypt
as well
>> because Egypt stands for the king of the
south right
>> so it's such a ridiculous philosophy
>> 100% what you're saying because that was
lit literal king of the south and So
yeah, we don't have to get into that
>> get into them.
>> But in any case, we have these power
plays that are taking place
>> and people want to read prophetic issues
into this. We're not looking at this.
We're looking at a global stage, not a
dispensationalist stage.
So let's listen to the speeches here
that were made by uh Trump and
Netanyahu. potentially one of the great
days ever in civilization.
Things that have been going on for
hundreds of years and thousands of
years. We're going to
at least we're at a minimum very very
close. And I think we're beyond very
close. And I'm not just talking about
Gaza. Gaza is one thing, but we're
talking about much beyond Gaza.
The whole deal,
everything getting solved. It's called
peace in the Middle East. And I have
just concluded an important meeting on
many vital issues, including Iran,
trade, the expansion of the Abraham
Accords,
and most importantly, we discussed how
to end the war in Gaza, but it's just a
part of the bigger picture, which is
peace in the Middle East, and let's call
it eternal peace in the Middle East. I
have a feeling that we're going to have
a positive answer. But if not, as you
know, BB, you'd have more full backing
to do what you would have to do.
Everyone understands that the ultimate
result must be the elimination of any
danger. The tyranny of terror has to
end. And this is again uh something that
we're looking for. This is eternity.
This is for forever.
>> Martin, you think it is forever. peace
and safety
>> and then destruction.
>> Okay, but for the sake of the
discussion, what is this issue with
Israel?
>> That's what I want to please explain
because the whole world is fascinated
now with the situation of Israel and
this is really
the ecumenical
um group are looking to Israel. So
expand a little bit. All right. This uh
fascination with Zionism.
Now, Zionism is a political aspiration.
>> Uh most of the Jews that live in Israel
are secular Jews.
>> They're not religious at all. They're
totally secular. Of course, you have the
Orthodox movement which is religious,
but they're both accommodated there.
Uh but they all celebrate Shabbat
>> and you will find them together. Those
that are of the Orthodox group and those
that are secular celebrating and dancing
and and doing whatever they're doing and
uh being sort of entrenched in this mode
of thinking.
And the dispensationist belief of course
believes in these two streams
>> Mhm.
>> of promises. One to the Christian church
and one to the Jews. Not realizing that
the Christian is supposed to be the
continuation of the Jewish system
because if you recognize Christ as the
Messiah, you become Israel. So it's not
the Jews were a separate church and now
you got the Christian church.
>> No, you don't have two brides.
>> No.
>> And one husband. That's big.
There is one bride and one husband.
There's only one Messiah. There's not
two messiahs. What did that man from the
Sanhedrin say? They will not accept
Jesus as their Messiah. They prefer to
go to Awitz.
>> Didn't he say that?
>> That's it.
>> Well, Martin, that's a terrible thing to
say because the Jews also said, "Wish we
had died in the wilderness and they got
their wish."
>> Yeah.
>> All right. It's a terrible thing to say.
Now, I'm not saying there will be
another Awitz, but I'm saying that there
could be a calamity.
But what is the idea? If there are these
two streams according to
dispensationalism, which is not in the
Bible by the way, then what is the idea?
The idea is that the Jews must all
return to Palestine. They must all
return to Israel. That's where they must
live.
So does that mean that the entire Jewish
belief system must be transllocated
to Israel? Well, they started that after
the Second World War.
>> Hitler handed them out of Germany.
They escaped out of the Eastblock
countries and many of them went to
Israel. M
>> and isn't it interesting that the allies
that were against the Germans
were the ones that put up the block
blockades to make sure that everybody
goes to Israel. And wasn't it the
British
>> that uh basically set up the state of
Israel?
>> Yeah.
>> And then it was accepted by the United
Nations. So it was a a movement to
create this religious ideology that
there are really two brides.
>> The Christian
and the Jew.
>> Yeah.
>> Now which rel religious system will
prevail?
>> The one or the other? Well, obviously if
you are in a Christian country, then you
like we have discussed many times as
Doug Wilson also said, then you will
adhere to the Christian norm
>> which includes Sunday keeping.
>> That's it.
>> And if you are a Jew that wants to be
orthodox and keep the Sabbath, then
please go to Israel.
>> Yeah.
>> If you want to be a totally secular Jew
and don't care about any of these
things, well then subject yourself to
the rules of the land.
>> Yeah. And if you want to be an Adventist
and you want to pretend that you're
keeping the Sabbath like the Jews keep
it, well then better change your view
because you get going to a conflict and
it will be the lesser of two evils if
you suffer persecution as a consequence.
>> Isn't that what we discussed?
>> It discussed it will be better to have
that persecution than what we have now.
>> Correct. So you have the
>> That's what they said, not what we said.
>> Yes. So if you have the two systems and
all those that really believe in the
orthodoxy then please go and live in
Israel where you can live under those
rules.
>> You can keep the Sabbath there
>> and an Adventist will be unwelcome there
or in the Christian world. So
>> because like you explained if you keep
the if you're not a Jew but you keep the
Sabbath like the Jews
>> then you're you're worthy of death
according to the Talmud. So once the
temple is there, those laws can be put
in place. And Donald Trump said, "We are
so close. We're doing this. We're
actually cleaning it up so that the Jews
can actually live there and we're going
to create a paradise. We're going to
create a paradise."
Beautiful. And it's going to last
forever.
>> Yeah,
>> Martin.
>> This is an earthly thing again. This is
so interesting for sure. And Martin,
what if you are sucked into the
philosophy that you have to now be
involved in the second bride and
watching her and what's happening
between Turkey and and the the Middle
Eastern nature's countries. Didn't he
say the Abrahamic accord will take care
of that?
>> Yeah.
He said and he also mentioned in that
speech that they want Iran to join it as
well.
>> All right. So Islam will be Islamic and
Israel will be Jewish.
>> Get used to it. And that's the way it's
going to be. All right. But Martin, not
only ideologically is it moving into
this false
Jesuit theology
>> Yeah.
of two separate brides of Christ, the
Jewish nation and the Christian world.
Not only on the religious level, but
also on the economic level
>> because the mark of the beast is also
implicated with economic measures,
buying and selling, right? So that has
to come to fruition as well.
>> Yeah. Now, let's look at what's
happening on that front.
>> Okay.
>> All around the world. You've been
warning about this since what, 2010,
2011, and here we are.
>> Yeah. Thank you for having me, Glenn.
And the first article I did, I went back
and looked 2010 in the New American
Magazine. I warned about a similar
proposal in the United States. They
wanted to bring in a national biometric
ID that would be required to work. And
here's the kicker. It was actually
paired with amnesty for illegal
immigrants. So, this new scheme that
they're working on in the United
Kingdom, they're marketing it as a
method of reigning in illegal
immigration, but it really has nothing
to do with illegal immigration. It's an
effort to force everybody into this
system. And they say, you know, first
it'll be to work, next it'll be to shop,
it'll be for your health care, it'll be
for your government benefits. And it's
coming at us like a freight train. A few
years after they first proposed it in
2010, Obama started pushing an idea that
we needed a digital ID to go on the
internet so that we couldn't be
anonymous anymore online. Uh we need to
be clear this is a tool for
totalitarianism. And then you listen to
Klaus Schwab's recent comments on the
fourth industrial revolution just a few
years ago where he said ultimately we
want a fusion of our biological and our
digital identities. This stuff is crazy
and if Americans and if people around
the world don't stand up, we're going to
lose our freedom. England.
>> The digital ID now is being pushed in
England. Uh and it it it does encompass
everything. Um Switzerland has just done
it. I believe Australia has done it. Uh
and it started earlier in in India if
I'm not mistaken. They were the first to
go really deep into this and it was a
disaster. Can you tell me what happened
when they launched that?
>> Yeah, that was fascinating. I was
covering that as well, Glenn. They
insisted that every last person in India
have one of these things. It had all
their biometric data and they basically
made it impossible to live without it. I
was just in India a few months ago on a
mission trip and I was told that every
single person in the entire country must
have a smartphone to be able to interact
with society. They used it for vaccine
passports. Now they use it for banking.
They use it to get uh any any kind of
relationship with government or even
companies. I went into a store and tried
to buy a dress for my wife. I couldn't
even buy that without a digital app
something on a smartphone which of
course I didn't have because I don't
have a smartphone. So this became
ubiquitous and what happened in India
the total incompetence rolling it out
they had people who were not able to
access food and other essentials of
life. Uh it ended up becoming a giant
dumpster fire. Of course Bill Gates was
haunting this in the shadows and and I
talked about this on your show last year
Glenn. The the digital ID is one
component of the digital public
infrastructure that Bill Gates and the
United Nations have already publicly
announced they're working on. It will be
melded with the central bank digital
currency and all of the other digital
architecture they're building to create
essentially a digital goolag for
humanity. Now Martin, I listened to the
speech of the the UK prime minister's
drama
and he
straight out said, "You either have it
or you will never work. You will never
be able to take part in society
>> and it's a done deal. It's going to
happen. Take it or leave it."
>> Now, it's fascinating whether it would
be a lefty or a righty that brings it
in. It doesn't matter. It's there to
stay. Right.
>> Now I want you to please let's just make
for viewers or listeners that has not
heard this before. This is not the mark
of the beast.
>> Of course it's not the mark of the
beast. It is the power that they will
use to enforce the mark of the beast.
And the mark of the beast can only be
defined by the beast itself. And the
beast is Roman Catholicism
because that is what the scriptures
state. They give the parameters. We can
look at it in a moment.
And it is clearly identified as the
papal system. And the papal system says
that the mark of their ecclesiastical
power is that they have shifted the
somnity of the Sabbath to the Sunday
>> because the mark of authority, the sign,
the seal that the god is in control has
been shifted to them that they are in
control. So it is a symbol of whose
authority is binding.
>> That's why they've got the keys. That's
why they have the key. And whatever they
loose and whatever they bind, it's like
the law of the Mes and the Persians. You
cannot change it. Now the power that God
gave the church when Jesus gave the keys
to the church
>> not to the papacy gave it to the church
on the recognation that recognition that
he is the son of God and no one else and
no earthly prelate
that power whoever wields that power is
the one that uh you have to watch out
for if he misuses that power. That power
was an ecclesiastical power to determine
who is in right standing with the church
or not had nothing to do with politics
whatsoever.
>> So modern many years ago
I gave a series of lectures and uh there
was a whistleblower from the World Bank
that came out and her name was Karen
Hudis. Uh the poor lady has disappeared
from the radar since then, but she was
very adamant and had discovered some
very interesting things. And perhaps we
can just play that to show who's behind
the financial system and therefore also
behind the the digital ID. Now
interesting.
>> Mhm.
>> This digital ID, is it purely political
or are the are the oligarchs involved?
Isn't it the Bill Gateses and the
and all the high tech people like Elon
Musk etc are involved in this?
>> Yeah. No, the merchants are involved in
it. The political sphere is involved in
it.
>> All right. So, let's have a look at this
one just as a reminder of some past
history.
>> Now, here's an interview which is rather
fascinating.
And this interview, if we can have the
sound up in a moment, this interview is
with a whistleblower. Now,
whistleblowers are causing quite a bit
of trouble for the current regimes. And
this is no ordinary whistleblower. This
was one of the advisory lawyers in the
International Monetary Fund. This is one
of the whistleblowers who blew the
whistle on multi-billion frauds. And
eventually for her whistleblowing she
got a pink slip. But let's listen to
what this person with her insight within
the financial systems of the world has
come up with in her thinking.
>> Hello, I'm Greg Hunter. Welcome to
usawatchdog.com.
With us today, a brand new guest. Her
name is Karen Hudis. She is an attorney,
she is a banker, and she is a
whistleblower. Karen Hudis, thank you so
much for joining us today from Maryland.
Thank you so much. Well, you worked for
the World Bank for a better part of 20
years. You are Ivy League trained
attorney. Uh you are went to Ivy League
school. I think you went to Yale. Uh you
uh you worked for the World Bank as a
lawyer. You're a banker. And you were a
whistleblower inside the World Bank. Not
just one time, but several times a
crescendo with a a big almost a billion
dollar uh you know whistleblowing fraud
malfeasants in the World Bank in
Indonesia. And for that you got a pink
slip in 2009. Getting back to the
Federal Reserve and the Bank for
International Settlements,
um these groups are in cahoots with the
biggest crooks of all, the Jesuits that
bought up Bank of America, and they have
little secret deals to try to
ao aortion the riches of the world. And
in the meantime, all of the countries of
the world know that this thievery is
going on. We are talking about the
biggest thugery of all and that is the
Jesuits in the Vatican. And let me tell
you what I just found out. Um I always
thought that the CIA was the problem and
the you know the other intelligence
agencies. Guess what? There's a grand
intelligence agency that the Vatican
puts out and all of those other crooks
are operating under the Vatican
intelligence agency.
>> The money is about
>> what's going on. The money is about the
control. And the the Vatican
intelligence agency, the World
Intelligence A, they're talking about
we're fighting over money, over what
money we're going to use.
>> Thing I'm saying, Greg, they're not
fighting. They've all agreed.
The fighting is what we're led to
believe. They're all in cahoots. Just
like all the banks are in cahoots, all
of these intelligence agencies are in
cahoots, too. For example, people don't
know that their IRS revenue is going to
the Vatican.
>> Martin, I don't know. Should I laugh or
should I cry?
>> I think we You're not laughing because
it's funny. You're laughing because Wow.
>> It's so true.
>> It's so true. It fits so in. And
nothing's changed. We've been You've
been saying this since then that she's
been saying it. Nothing's changed. And
now you can actually see this.
>> All right. So, who's behind it?
>> The Jesuits.
>> The Jesuits. Now, what are the Jesuits?
>> Well, we'll put up a slide just now and
have the Vatican answer what the Jesuits
are and who they are and what their
purpose is
>> so that the Vatican says it and not we
because then we will be conspiracy
theorists again to some of these uh
deceived individuals that don't see a
conspiracy behind the scenes.
All right. So, let's have a look at all
of these intelligence agencies, whether
they be CIA or whether they be FBI
or whether they be MI6 or whether they
be KGB or whether they be MOSSAD or
whatever you want to call them. They're
all plugged in
>> to the main
>> to the main power source. this umbrella
mega intelligence agency, the Sanka
Aliance is just a portion of it. It's
secret assassination police.
>> So the FBI suspects
Michigan church shooter hated people of
the Mormon faith.
Now these things are becoming prevalent,
right? And you had the assassination of
Charlie Kirk
>> and we're now seeing more and more
religious assassinations.
>> Yeah. Just before that we had that
shooting at the Catholic church
>> and now we've had that rampage at the
synagogue in in England. Yeah.
>> So, it was the latest of many shooting
attacks on houses of worship in the
United States over the past 20 years,
including one in August that killed two
children during mass at the Church of
the Annunciation in Minneapolis. So,
that was Catholic.
And then in a post on September 28,
President Donald Trump praised the FBI
for its response to the Michigan
shooting. And this epidemic of violence
in our country must end immediately,
Trump said. He also said the shooting
and arson on 28th September were another
yet another targeted attack on
Christians
and called for prayer.
Now Martin,
how do I say this carefully?
If you invoke the name of Christ,
>> does it make you a Christian
organization? Unfortunately, not. And
that's what we we've been trying to
explain through there's perfect criteria
to be a a true Christian.
>> Yes.
>> And if you don't adhere to that, then if
you call yourself a Christian, even a
Christian church, that doesn't make it
true.
>> Okay. In other words, Martin, if we say
to the law,
>> Mhm.
>> and to the testimony.
>> Yeah. If they speak not according to
this word, there's no light in them.
So, do you think there will be many that
will speak contrary to the law?
>> Yes.
>> All right. That's the Torah. Does the
Torah, the first five books of the
Bible, does it contain the Ten
Commandments?
>> Yes.
>> So, if you speak contrary to the Ten
Commandments, you have no light in you.
Right.
>> Does the papacy speak contrary to the
Ten Commandments?
>> Yes.
>> They changed them. Right.
>> They changed it. Yeah.
Do the evangelicals, many of them speak
contrary to the law?
>> Yes. Because it says done away with.
>> Then there must be no light in them.
>> To the testimony, that's what's written
in the Bible. By the way, the Torah, the
very first sentence, does it talk about
creation?
>> Yes.
>> So, if you're an evolutionist, then you
have no light in you.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that correct?
>> Unfortunately. So if you are an academic
teaching at the university and you
invoke evolutionism in your subjects
then you are dark.
>> Yeah.
>> You have no light.
>> And if you are a Christian institution,
church, whatever, and you also do that,
that also pushes you out.
>> Okay. So if Christ says, "Come unto me
and I will give you rest."
Martin, does that mean if you come unto
the Pope that he will give you rest?
>> No.
>> No. So, is that against the testimony?
>> Yes.
>> So, Martin, it's not so prevalent that
if you invoke the name of Jesus that you
are necessarily a Christian
organization.
>> Definitely not.
>> Why did Brigham Young, the prophet of
the Mormons, say the devil told the
truth about Godhead? Has the devil ever
told the truth about anything?
>> No. He's a liar from the beginning.
>> Huh?
>> He would not have missed Mother Eve
eating the forbidden fruit for anything.
>> Martin, didn't the eating the forbidden
fruit plunge the world into chaos?
>> That's why we're sitting in this
nonsense.
>> Uh, is there any indication that there
is a father god in the Bible?
>> No.
>> Why do the Mormons believe that then?
>> Yeah.
So you know using the name of Jesus. Now
please understand me.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> There are millions of people in all of
these organizations
that don't see the depth of it. The only
focus but you know we do sing about
Jesus and we do love Jesus
but what is the definition of his role
>> and what is he doing and who is his
representative
and uh what was dismant
involvement in the creation of the you
the Mormon movement. So if you invoke
this name Jesus then you are h
interestingly a Christian according to
>> the world and the norm. Now these
Christians will they be in line with the
papal standard of the ten commandments
or with the biblical standard?
>> There are very few that are in line with
the biblical.
>> Okay. So let's just get that straight
>> and then we can also just state there
it's not that we say that killing or all
these atrocities is justified
>> never because it's not because they're
not justified.
>> Yeah. Because they don't qualify as a
Christian church. That doesn't mean that
it's okay to do this. But they this is
being used
for a purpose.
>> Yes.
>> By the powers that be. And those that
are radicalized
to create violence, who and what
radicalized them?
>> Yeah, that's very important.
>> Who is the power behind the scene?
>> And just go through history and you'll
see how many times this power behind the
scenes was the driving force for the
radicalism.
>> Yeah. Whether it was the hippie movement
or whether it was the French Revolution,
we can go on and on forever. Whether it
was the Civil War, whether it was
whatever,
>> what whatever is right because when you
we look at some of the lectures in the
past that you had even alcohol, coffee,
chocolate, all of this,
>> anything that destroys your brain was
brought in by the Jesuits. Now, let's
just listen to what Donald Trump said
about climate change and issues of that
nature.
1982, the executive director of the
United Nations Environmental Program
predicted that by the year 2000, climate
change would cause a global catastrophe.
He said that it will be irreversible
as any nuclear holocaust would be. This
is what they said at the United Nations.
What happened? Here we are. Another UN
official stated in 1989 that within a
decade entire nations could be wiped off
the map by global warming. Not
happening.
You know, it used to be global cooling.
If you look back years ago in the 1920s
and the 1930s, they said global cooling
will kill the world. We have to do
something. Then they said global warming
will kill the world. But then it started
getting cooler. So now they could just
call it climate change because that way
they can't miss. It's climate change
because if it goes higher or lower,
whatever the hell happens, there's
climate change.
It's the greatest conj job ever
perpetrated on the world. In my opinion,
climate change, no matter what happens,
you're involved in that. modern
you see this is where I align myself
with something that I find amusing
>> but that's why we said so some things
that they say he's 100% correct
>> correct so the issue is not is there
climate change it's a load of nonsense I
really believe exactly like he believes
there but the fact of the matter is it
must serve some purpose
>> that's what I'm interested in
>> of course and even though he says that
he still knows the bigger plan.
>> Yes. So, the narrative must be kept
alive in spite of what Donald Trump
said.
>> So, let's just have a look at the Pope
and his little ice cube. Yeah.
Wow.
Lord of life,
bless this water.
May it awaken our hearts,
cleanse our indifference,
soothe our grief,
and renew our hope through Christ our
Lord.
>> Amen.
>> So, Martin, the Pope blessed the ice
cube. I'm so glad it wasn't so cold that
his hand got stuck to it because he had
it on there for quite a while, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Maybe it was a hot day and he needed to
cool off. So, here it says the BBC
reports that Pope Leo condemns climate
change critics. So, did he just rebuke
Donald Trump?
>> Definitely.
>> Okay.
So Pabla has hit out at those who
minimize the increasingly evident impact
of rising temperatures in his first
major statement on climate change. So he
reiterated the words of his predecessor
Pope Francis. After all these popes are
infallible, so they can't be wrong,
right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. One can't say this and the
other one something else.
>> So the new pontiff lambbasted critics
who ridicule those who speak of global
warming.
I'm shriveling under the lamp basting.
The Pope's remarks at the speech in
Castell Gond Dulo near Rome will be seen
as an implied criticism of Donald Trump.
All right, he called it a conj job. The
pope said that each of us will have to
answer a question from God. God will ask
us if we have cultivated and cared for
the world that he created for the
benefit of all and for future
generations. And if we have taken care
of our brothers and sisters, what will
be our answer, my dear friends? So in
other words, what's important here is
that the narrative must be kept alive.
That's true. Because if you read that
portion of that in in the Bible, yes,
sure, you have to take care of your
brothers and of nature and all of that,
but not in the way that they're doing
it.
>> No. So what is the reason why the
narrative must be kept alive? obviously
because they want climate change
legislation
and the only ones that they're going to
get probably is Sunday legislation
because one day of rest will bring down
the CO2 emission by a fantastic
percentage.
>> So you see how clever this plan is.
>> Yes. Because even though Donald Trump
can be saying that he will still be okay
when the Donald Trump implements or
whenever the beast this image of the
beast implements the Sunday
for whatever reason the climate will
just fit into it perfectly for
themselves. Okay. So let's get back to
the nitty-gritty.
If we look at our feature
uh backdrop here, the United States is
plugged into the power source, right?
>> And it has been from the beginning.
There has been Masonic Jesuit influence
from the beginning. You have all the
Jesuit universities running the show in
the United States of America, presidents
being educated by Jesuit philosophy.
They're everywhere,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> And church and state has to come
together because that's what you had in
the middle ages when the church didn't
have a mortal wound.
>> The mortal wound will be healed.
So what did he say about church and
state? Let's just make sure. We're
bringing back religion in our country
and we're bringing it back quickly and
strongly
because for America to be a great
nation, we must always be one nation
under God. A phrase that they would like
to get rid of the radical left. But Ben,
I don't think we're going to let them
get rid of that, right? We will make
America rich and healthy again. And why
don't we say rich, healthy, and
religious again? Okay, shall I add that
for this group? Right, Dan Patrick? And
you know they work right out of the
White House. They've never done that.
That's never been done before. No other
president allowed that. I think you know
they say separation
they say separation between church and
state. They told me I said all right
let's forget about that for one time. We
said really the separation? I don't
know. Is that a good thing or a bad
thing? I'm not sure. But whether there's
separation or not, you guys are in the
White House where you should be and
you're representing our country and
we're bringing religion back to our
country and uh it's a big deal. I
created a historic White House faith
office in the West Wing and that's going
to be an office that's been very well I
see already you have a lot of people
going back and forth and that's good.
That's why we want to defend and
represent people of all faiths and their
religious freedoms at home and at and
abroad. And I wanted them to have that
office. Never happened before. I don't
think that's ever happened before.
Right. They people of faith have never
been allowed in the White House. We'll
probably be sued tomorrow because
they're going to say church separation
of church and state. Can't do that,
right? But we'll win. Pam will Pam will
win that suit. She wins them. She she
ultimately she wins them. She gets them.
Sometimes they get a little a judge
that's not so good, but she ultimately
wins. That's what it's all about, right,
Pam? I signed an executive order to
combat anti-semitism. It's a big thing,
a big thing.
And I set up a DOJ task force, which is
really a big thing. And Dan, you're
going to be involved in it to eradicate
anti-Christian bias. you haven't heard
that, but there's anti-Christian bias
also. And in just a few moments, I'll
also be signing an executive order
creating a presidential commission on
religious liberty, which is really why
we're here. The chairman is Texas
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick, whose
idea this was. And stand up, Dan.
What a great guy.
What a great political person.
He's a amazing politician, Lieutenant
Governor, and he's a very a man of great
religion. Thank you very much, Dan. As
well as Dr. Ben Carson. Ben, I don't
have to say much about Ben. I don't have
to say much.
He's been with me from the beginning.
You know, he was campaigning against me
originally. Can I tell that story, Ben?
You mind? Are you sure you don't mind?
because he was campaigning. He was very
effective and he was going up in the
polls and and uh he looked at me about
three or four debates in and he said,
"You know you're going to win by a lot,
don't you?" This was during 2016.
And I said, "What do you mean, Ben? What
do you mean? You're you're campaigning.
Don't say that, Ben. You're campaigning.
You have a shot." He was a little bit
behind, but pretty far far enough. But
he said, "You know, you're going to win.
These people can't beat you. Nobody's
going to be able to beat you." I said,
"Why?" He said, "Because God is with
you." I said, "That's nice."
Then he said it once again in the
church. Remember that, Ben? He pulled me
over. He said, "Remember what I told
you? God is with you." There's never
been a president who has invoked the
name of Jesus more than you.
There's never been a president who says,
"Yes, I love Jesus, but I live love
people of all faith." As Dr. Phil said,
you have a heart for every American, and
you're showing that today. Um, I'm proud
to represent you as chair, proud to have
Ben Carson as our vice chair and every
member of this committee. We will serve
you, we will serve the people, and most
importantly, we will serve God. Thank
you, Mr. President. And under President
Donald Trump's leadership, faith has not
been pushed aside. It has been brought
back to where it always belongs. And
that is center.
>> We're bringing back religion in our
country. And we're bringing it back, as
I say, bigger and better and stronger
than ever before. Thank you all very
much.
>> So, we've established that church and
state is going to come together.
>> Mhm. and this administration is going to
push for it. They have a short window in
which to do this.
>> Yeah,
>> they have certain events taking place
and without getting into the
conspiracies of to as to exactly what
happened there. The outcome is that it
can be used to create the momentum
>> defin well I I don't think anybody can
negate that. It's definitely put
momentum in. So let's listen to some of
the speeches just to refresh our memory
and then we will discuss some of the
political ramifications.
>> On his last day, Charlie Kirk was on the
top of a mountain and Charlie Kirk led
us there and Charlie Kirk has brought us
to the promised land.
Charlie's death was not just a murder.
The true word for what Charlie did
is sacrifice.
You see, the difference between murder
and sacrifice
is that sacrifice is a gift. Our
civilization will endure. The United
States of America will endure. For
Charlie, we will continue the mission.
For Charlie, we will end the evil
disease that split us and took Charlie
from us. And for Charlie, Turning Point
USA will last forever.
This is THE PLACE. THIS IS THE TURNING
point for Charlie.
When I see Erica and her strength and
her courage,
I am reminded of a famous expression.
The storm whispers to the warrior
that you cannot withstand my strength.
And the warrior whispers back, "I am the
storm."
Erica is the storm.
Our lineage and our legacy hails back to
Athens, to Rome, to Philadelphia, to
Montichello. Our ancestors built the
cities. They produced the art and
architecture. They built the industry.
Erica stands on the shoulders of
thousands of years of warriors of women
who raised up families, raised up city,
raised up industry,
raised up civilization,
who pulled us out of the caves and the
darkness into the light. The light will
defeat the dark. We are the ones who
build. We are the ones who create. We
are the ones who lift up humanity.
You thought you could kill Charlie Kirk?
You have made him immortal. You have
immortalized Charlie Kirk. You have no
idea the dragon you have awakened. You
know, Marco mentioned this arena and the
millions watching.
A couple days ago, I learned that Kirk
actually in German in German, the German
language
means church.
So on this Sunday morning, I'd like to
think we're all in Charlie's church.
Charlie or Christ
died at 33 years old.
But he changed the trajectory of
history.
Charlie died at 31 years old. But
because he had surrendered,
he also now has changed the trajectory
of history.
>> Pray again. Read the Bible again.
go to church next Sunday and the Sunday
after that and break free from the
temptations and shackles of this world.
>> He was a missionary with a noble spirit
and a great great purpose. He did not
hate his opponents. He wanted
the best for them. That's where I
disagreed with Charlie.
I hate my opponent
and I don't want the best for them. I'm
sorry. I am sorry, Erica.
But now Erica can talk to me and the
whole group and maybe they can convince
me that that's not right. But I can't
stand my opponent.
[Applause]
>> Charlie's angry looking down. He's angry
at me now.
[Music]
Martin, if you looked at that from an
emotional point of view, you will be
swept into a certain pattern of
activity, right?
>> Y
>> if you look at it from a conspiracist
point of view, then it's actually quite
challenging.
>> The first speaker held up a rosary.
>> Yeah.
Is there any point in that or is that
aligning yourself with a particular
Christian so-called ideology?
>> Yes.
>> Isn't the rosary Catholic?
>> Isn't it forbidden by the Bible to have
repetitive prayer?
>> Yes.
>> As an abomination?
>> It's very very in your face.
>> It's in your face.
And uh the rhetoric that you heard,
>> it was the warrior rhetoric. Mhm.
>> Then you had the military leader
Hexstead and he was also invoking this
power, right?
>> Yeah. The church and he brings the whole
thing back to church. Interesting. The
other guy that said you have awakened
the dragon, light and dark, always that
yinyang thing.
>> Yes. And then finally you had uh the
proclamation that the enemy needs to be
basically eradicated
by Donald Trump. And then you had some
interesting hand signals which we don't
have to go into detail
>> because if you saw them you saw them.
What do they mean? What do they mean to
certain people? Are they incidental? Are
they signals? Are they not? So let's not
go into the conspiracies, but let's look
at
>> the consequence.
And then Pete Hexet had the
secretary
of war as the secretary of war had this
massive meeting with all the brass of
the military and those speeches were
fascinating.
Good morning and welcome to the War
Department
because the era of the Department of
Defense is over.
You see, the motto of my first platoon
was those who long for peace must
prepare for war. This is of course not a
new idea. This crowd knows that. The
origin dates to the 4th century Rome and
has been repeated ever since, including
by our first commander-in-chief,
George Washington, the first leader of
the War Department. It captures a simple
yet profound truth. To ensure peace, we
must prepare for war. From this moment
forward, the only mission of the newly
restored Department of War is this:
war fighting. preparing for war and
preparing to win. Unrelenting and
uncompromising in that pursuit. Not
because we want war. No one here wants
war.
But it's because we love peace. We love
peace for our fellow citizens. They
deserve peace and they rightfully expect
us to deliver it. Our number one job, of
course, is to be strong so that we can
prevent war in the first place. The
president talks about it all the time.
It's called peace through strength.
And as history teaches us, the only
people who actually deserve peace are
those who are willing to wage war to
defend it.
He used some very strong explicits
to defend his statement and he started
off his speech by referring to Rome.
>> Mhm.
>> Again,
>> everything goes back to Rome. We'll see
that in a moment.
Interestingly, he's reversing woke.
>> Yeah. and he's uh propagating
the masculinity and the strength.
So he instates the highest male standard
only for combat. Other changes declared
during the department of defense is
over. He said it must restore a
ruthless, dispassionate and common sense
application of standards. We're training
warriors, not defenders. We fight wars
to win, not to defend. Defense is
something you all do all the time. It's
inherently
reactionary and can lead to overuse,
overreach, and mission creep. War is
something you do sparingly, on your own
terms, and with clear aims. He said as
he spoke on Tuesday morning. So
basically, he says, "Enemies beware.
We're not going to tread softly. We're
going to wipe you off the face of the
earth. You either do what you're told or
else. Is that the dragon
>> making his voice heard?
>> Is it um the lamb speaking as a dragon?
>> That's a fascinating question, Martin.
He tells the troops to resign if they
oppose his plan to scrap woke policies
and restore warrior ethos.
If the words I'm speaking today are
making your heart sink, then you should
do the honorable thing and resign. Heg
said to the audience, "We would thank
you for your service, but I suspect the
overwhelming majority of you feel the
opposite. These words make your hearts
full. We're not a woke department
anymore."
>> No. If you want to have all of these
curly hairs or something, then join the
special ops where you go underground to
to infiltrate certain groups, right?
And uh fascinating what he all says. And
I we don't have to go into the acronym
far.
>> No,
>> because it's not fitting for a
ministry to use an acronym like that.
>> But they are definitely serious. All
right. Now, Martin, has this got
anything to do with religion?
>> It's not. It's not seed anymore. It's
not church and state or war and state.
Now, it's definitely got to do
>> Why do you have a statement like this?
>> Why do the caller to come to Jesus
meeting?
What is this? Isn't this a an implant
into your mind?
>> Of course. So the military community
reacts to Hexit's get fit, get in line,
or get out speech. We don't have to go
into it at all. But it's interesting
what some of these people were saying.
We're not going to walk on eggshells. If
we give a command to go and kill those
people, then so be it.
>> You don't have to be politically correct
anymore. You're going to do what you're
told. It's going to be a command. And
then the come to Jesus. Come to Jesus.
One of the most interesting articles to
come out of the pens of journalism
>> in the last few days
is this article in desper.
This is Germany's time magazine
>> to the power of 10.
Goddess
God's warriors. Yeah. All right. And the
the the cover says it all.
Number one, you have Donald Trump with
the halo or the sun behind him,
whatever.
>> Mhm.
With the Bible in his hand.
There's a cross on the other side.
You have the new military commander that
we just heard
>> uh with a very aggressive face on this
side.
You have Bondi over there.
>> Justice.
And then you have this face over here.
That's fascinating to me that they put
that face in there. Douglas Wilson,
right?
And then you have the vice president of
the United States who claimed to have
been an a atheist just recently then
became Catholic but is involved in the
evangelical movement. Evangelical
Catholicism
>> by the way that is the same category
that Hexet falls under.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But there's something that
um is like glue that makes the change
over that or the bonding that it's okay
to say that. Isn't that what you were
speaking about earlier? The power the
Holy Spirit because they have a movement
of
>> now people must must look at Clash of
Minds in totality.
Clash of Minds is not just what's up
Prof.
Clash of minds is also what is truth
>> and many of the subjects that are dealt
with in what's what is truth
back up
>> for sure
>> the the narrative of what's a prof
>> and dives a little bit deeper.
>> Yes. And gives the background and the
theology. We've done it in the past.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now,
>> now the generation Z of Clash of Minds
is involved in that and I think they did
an excellent job on speaking in tongues
and glossalia in their recent ones
>> in the latest one.
>> Correct. And I think there's another one
coming out on the issue.
>> I think so. Yeah.
>> Please look at that. Give these young
people a chance. see what they are
producing to show where these movements
come from. Now when I look at this
picture and I look at God's amazing
grace, how he enabled us to have an
interview with one of the individuals on
this picture,
right, Douglas Wilson. And that
interview was about church and state and
it was specifically about the Sabbath.
>> Yeah.
and how that entire team basically said
you better shape up or ship out.
>> That's it.
>> The majority will
decide what will be done. Now the source
of this power
here you have the vice president who is
very vocal.
He claims to be Catholic
but is involved with the evangelicals as
well. Then you have Hexet who doesn't
claim to be Catholic and sits in one of
these evangelical massive movements that
have just moved very close to the White
House and attends the church of Douglas
Wilson.
>> Yeah.
>> Which we interviewed together with
Heritage and Hope.
>> Mhm.
>> And this is really mindboggling where we
are heading because everybody needs to
be informed on this issue.
Now when you read this article
>> Yeah.
It reads like total onslaught.
It talks about all of the issues. It
talks about
the role players and their connection
with Catholicism and with the eangelical
movement. So in other words, it's it's
like the ecumenical issue. And they are
warriors for God. They are Christian
nationalists.
They are establishing the kingdom on
earth.
>> Yes. And they mentioned Paula White.
>> Yeah.
>> That uh Donald Trump just put in charge
of this religious arm of the White
House.
>> And she is a prosperity gospel preacher.
That's why he can say, "We're going to
be rich.
We're going to make America rich again."
And we have these mega
oligarchs and the multi-millionaires and
trillionaires in our midst. We're going
to use this power and we're going to
move ahead. We're going to be the
richest, most prosperous nation on the
globe. It's going to last for how long
did he say?
>> Forever.
>> This is very fascinating.
Very fascinating. They their their
speech, their dragon talk is telling you
where it all comes from.
>> And they said they're going to take this
government over.
>> Yeah.
>> And they're going to be in charge of
morality and make moral laws, including
the blue laws.
>> Mhm.
>> That's what came out in our discussion.
Right.
>> Yeah. Now, if I can just go
to my Bible
and turn to the book of Daniel
and just go to Daniel chapter 2.
And in Daniel chapter 2, of course, we
have the image
that Nebuchadnezzar dreamed about,
right? Yes.
And what if you drop down there to the
portion where he's run through the
images, the head of gold being Babylon,
the arms and of silver, and the the
breast being Meo Persia, then the hips
being Greece, and then the two legs
Rome, the Eastern and the Western
Empire. And then the feet of iron and
clay, the church craft and state craft
joined together.
>> And then it says in verse 44,
"And in the days of these kings,
>> Mhm.
>> shall the God of heaven set up a
kingdom."
Aren't they saying that it is them that
is setting up this kingdom?
>> Yes.
>> In that many words, right?
>> In well, exact words. Okay, that's what
they're going to do. But here it says
that the God of heaven will set up a
kingdom. Now, I find this interesting
because if you read this verse
carefully, it gives you another clue.
>> Which shall never be destroyed,
>> eternity?
>> Did they say that?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And the kingdom. Now, this is
fascinating because there's a
punctuation in between
and it says,
"And the kingdom shall not be left to
other people, but it shall break in
pieces and consume all these kingdoms,
and it shall stand forever." Martin, it
will not be left to people. Christ will
set it up.
>> Yeah.
So Martin, this is a false philosophy
>> for sure. This is Satan's philosophy
>> and it's global papal power because they
are propagating Catholicism. They're
holding up the rosaries. And this
article refers to the inconsistencies.
They ask the question, why does Hexet
have all the papal insignia? tattooed
onto his body, but he attends an
evangelical organization.
>> How do you link those two together?
>> Uh, this is very conspiratorial, Martin.
This is fascinating. Yeah. And of course
they are propagating this return to
masculinity and some of the arguments of
the left you know that there are are
issues here that seem to reflect uh a
move back to this maledominated
maybe even white dominated
>> patriarchy
>> patriarchal system
>> and uh implying that the the female vote
will be taken away And where's this all
heading to? Fascinating. Now, let's just
unpack it a little bit further.
Hexet wrote a book, I think it was in
2020, that's a few years ago now
already, which was called The American
Crusade,
Our Fight to Stay Free,
Pete Hexet. Now, isn't it interesting
that just a few years later,
>> he becomes the Secretary of Defense?
>> I don't think it's a coincidence.
>> And in this book, he calls it an
American crusade. Now, the crusaders
were there to expand
Catholicism.
>> Yeah.
>> It was a It was the papal knights.
>> Yes.
>> And the Knights Templars.
And the Knights Templars of course are
on the same level
as a 33 degree Freemason. They're right
on the top of the Masonic pile.
>> And if you go to the chosen, for
example, the actors are templars which
are on that same level and they're
portraying a particular image of Christ
which is anything but biblical. It's a
disaster.
It is a deception of the highest order.
>> In fact, it is pure Catholicism.
>> It's actually pure evil.
>> And the tattoos that he is wearing and
the swords that he is wielding, he's
wielding the sword of the state on
behalf of the church because why has he
got the crusader signs on his body?
These are Roman Catholic symbols on a
so-called evangelical.
But who is the source of the power
behind the power?
>> The dragon. Satan.
>> Satan. And who is his representative on
this earth? The man of sin.
>> Yeah. So if we take this very same Bible
and we move along to to Daniel chapter 7
where you have
uh a dream that Daniel had about all
these beasts that would arise, right?
Whether it was now the
Babylonian Empire as the lion with eagle
wings or the bear the Meo Persians that
was raised up on one side one of the
alliance partners being more powerful
than the other or whether we're talking
about Greece. just interesting as well
all those that you mentioned now was it
interesting that that one guy said from
Athens to Rome and he also brought it up
and then he said you've unleashed the
dragon
>> you've unleashed
>> talk was almost Daniel like
>> and the dragon gave him his power and
his seat and great authority right
>> and uh it's not coincidental that in our
backdrop over here that the United
States is the first one plugged in
there. It's in plug number one.
>> Yeah,
>> because the dragon gave him his power.
>> Yeah.
>> And he needs this military power. He
needs this economic power. He needs all
of these to push his agenda.
And then you can drop down to verse 15
and it says
uh that Daniel was grieved in his spirit
in the midst of my body and in the
visions of my head that troubled me. And
I came near unto one of them that stood
there in in his vision. He's talking to
the angel representatives.
And uh he told him basically what is
going to happen that these beasts are
four are four kings which shall arise
out of the earth and later they say a
king or a kingdom.
but that eventually the saints of the
most high shall take the kingdom and
possess the kingdom forever and forever
and ever.
>> Now the saints are those that adhere to
the law and the testimony. None of these
adhere to the law and the testimony.
They adhere to papal dogmas
>> and papal fallacies.
And they wanted to know the
truth of the fourth beast, which was
different, diverse
>> from all the others, exceedingly
dreadful, whose teeth were of iron.
Now, in the previous image, iron, of
course, was the symbol of Rome.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this is a Roman element,
>> and it's the teeth that were of iron.
Now, where do your teeth sit? They sit
in your mouth, right?
And uh it's his words have bite to them.
>> It's they have clout.
>> It's not like they say you have bark but
no bite.
>> No, this guy can bite. He's got teeth
>> and his nails of brass.
>> That's an illusion to his Greek
philosophy
which devoured break in pieces and
stamped the residue of his feet. Did he
not just say if you stand in our way we
will basically wipe you out, devour you?
>> Yep.
>> And then he wanted to know about the 10
horns which are reminiscent of the 10
toes, right?
>> The powers of Europe.
>> Mhm.
>> Where the clay and the iron, the
political and the religious strength
were vying with each others.
>> And sometimes they seem to adhere and
sometimes they didn't.
And then he wanted to know about this
little horn power before whom three
fell.
>> It's only in in Roman Catholicism when
it reached its ascendancy that three of
the original 10 horns had to be wiped
out.
The ruly, the Ostrogoths, and the
Vandals.
The last of them to fall with the
Ostrogoths. Well, there's a lot of
people that use this history and they
want to say that the reason why
Catholicism got rid of those three is
because they were anti-trinitarian.
>> That's one of the arguments that is
used. But the real reason is probably
because they were Sabbath keepers.
>> They were Sabbathke keepers.
>> And if you want to become a Sabbathke
keeper, then you could come into the
crossfire.
Martin, that was not a pun.
>> No.
>> And if it was a pun, it was an intended
one. Made people think about that.
Crossfire.
>> The other thing I wanted to say is they
might have been anti not
anti-trinitarian.
Anti-atholic trinitarian.
>> They might have been. Yes.
Anyway,
this power spoke very great words
and his look was more stout than his
fellows. He became very prescriptive
Catholicism.
>> And then it says in verse 21 that he
made war with the saints.
We have now no longer a secretary of
defense
but one of war.
>> War.
>> Oh, Martin, we are so close to the end.
And how long did this power rule?
>> Mhm.
>> Verse 22. Until the ancient of days came
and judgment was given to the saints of
the most high and the time came that the
saints possessed the kingdom.
So it's going to be taken away. This
bravado is going to be taken away.
Thus he said, "The fourth beast shall be
the fourth kingdom upon the earth, which
shall be diverse from all kingdoms, and
shall devour how much of this world?"
The whole earth.
>> Does that include the Russians and the
Chinese and all the others?
>> All and shall tread it down and break it
in pieces.
And the 10 horns of this kingdom are 10
kings that shall arise and another shall
arise after them. The papal power arose
in 538 as a political entity.
>> Therefore, it arose after the
destruction of Rome and the
establishment of the 10 toes of Europe.
And it is he
that is different from the others,
diverse from the first because he is a
religopolitical power.
>> And he shall subdue three kings. He'll
get rid of the Sabbathkeeping ones. He's
made war on the Sabbath ever since.
>> And he shall speak great words against
the most high. Will be a blasphemous
power. He shall make war against the
saints. So he will wear out the saints.
Martin, they're so worn out. They're in
an ecumenical movement dancing to his
tune.
>> Yeah. And the rest are snoring away.
>> Yes. They don't even have any teeth
left. The only one who has teeth is he.
>> Yeah.
>> And he will think to change times and
laws. He will be so arrogant to change
times and laws. The only commandment
that deals with time is the Sabbath
commandment. and he changed it.
And then there's this time that they
will be given into his hands. The
1,260day
period of papal supremacy, which ended
in 1798, went underground through the
French Revolution, is coming up in the
Department of War, making his voice like
a dragon, and he's going to force the
whole world to do the bidding of the
power that they're all plugged in.
>> The power doesn't lie with his military.
It doesn't lie with the FBI. It doesn't
lie with the CIA. It doesn't lie with
the KGB. It doesn't lie with the Mossad.
It doesn't lie with MI6. It lies with
global power.
>> Yeah.
>> It lies with the Jesuits as the general
of the greatest army.
>> Mhm.
>> That this world has ever seen. And that
man over there on the screen, Pete
Hexet, is wearing the insignia
of the papal power.
>> Yeah.
Martin, can you have it more blatant
than that?
>> I can't see how
hopefully everybody can now just sit
back, open your eyes, rewind, and go and
listen to this again and watch what's
happening in front of your eyes. Read
your Bible again, watch what we've just
shown, and then
>> stop trying to put this into another
power. Zionists, the Jews, everywhere
else. Open your eyes. This is what the
>> isolating one little organization
like Erdogan in Turkey and making the
bees knees. This is ridiculous. Look at
these powers. So Martin, let's get it
from the horse's mouth.
This is vatican.com
and it's an article from 2018.
It's not an article from the 1500s.
>> No.
And it talks about who and what are the
Jesuits, the Society of Jesus, the
Jesuit order. And let's read it at
least. Let's read the first portion.
The Jesuits focused on intellectual
research,
education, schools, higher education,
religious seminaries. They became the
school masters of Europe. It's history.
>> They run a plethora of universities and
those that they don't directly control,
they control indirectly. Period.
>> Yeah.
>> They are the school masters of the
world.
>> The curriculara of the world are
schooled upon Jesuit ideology whether we
like it or not. They became the theater
of the world. Mhm.
>> They are the ones when they couldn't
directly be involved in England brought
about the Shakespeareian era.
>> It was probably Sir Francis Bacon
uh Rosacrruian
Luciferian
papal
knight.
>> Yeah.
And they introduced
another level of mind control which
today culminates in Jesuit theater
Hollywood. Yeah.
>> Which literally means witch's stuff.
>> Witchcraft
>> and also even in
fanciful books.
>> Yes. So modern what is it that they did?
So research, education,
etc. And of course their research in
includes astronomy and all of these
things
>> even evolution
>> and evolution and their hoaxes their
pulled down hoaxes all perpetrated by
Jesuits.
Some of the most prominent universities
in the world and especially in the US
were founded originally by the Jesuit
order and some are still run by it.
comes from the Vatican page.
What else does it say? The order was
founded just before the official
Counterreformation movement began. The
Society for Jesus was founded by
Ignatius of Lyola. Ignatius was a
Spanish highborn knight who decided to
found the society following his
conversion. He had a religious
conversion after he was wounded in the
battle of Pmplona in 1521.
Moved profoundly by his religious
experiences, Ignatius decided to devote
his life to his faith and religious
teachings and exercises. He was greatly
inspired by St. Francis of Aissi after
which Pope Francis named himself.
So here we have the whole background.
He's a papal knight and he was to
spearhead the counterreformation because
they're very careful here. They say it
was founded just before
>> the official counterreformation
movement. So who was to spearhead it?
Ignashius and the Jesuits
>> and they introduced this massive
massive organization
that was to infiltrate every single
government. It was a secret society.
>> It was a FBI
and a CIA to the power of a billion.
And under it all the affiliates would
come
and they would all behind the scenes
draw their power from the same source.
>> So Martin this is the introduction to
this document. You will post the link of
the entire document.
>> They can see the link on the screen. It
will be posted as well.
>> It is self-evident that there is nothing
hidden that will not be revealed. This
organization has spent more blood than
any other.
And uh it is a a military truth
that one of the books that was probably
written by a Jesuit general, the art of
war,
>> which I talk about in the series Creed
to Malta,
is uh one of those that has to be
studied by every general probably in the
United States of America. and surely has
been studied in detail by Pete.
>> These people are behind assassinations
of unwanted
political and religious figures. These
people are behind the fermentation of
wars of revolutions
and now they have come to the front with
their papal knights masquerading as
evangelicals
and they will implement the papal
agenda. The mark of the beast will be
proclaimed and we are going to head for
the final conflict
>> and the people of God have a decision to
make to the law and to the testimony. If
they speak not according to this word,
they have no light in them. Let's pray.
>> Let's get ready.
Heavenly Father,
I feel it in my bones
that we have reached the culmination of
history.
The dragon is speaking
and the dragon has a very distinct
agenda which he has clearly outlined and
it has come to four in our recent
discussions
with some of the role players depicted
on the cover of Deshbigel.
Grant us the strength.
And may I ask Lord that you grant us the
power
because as many as believed
on his name, he gave power
to become the sons of God.
May we invoke the true power of the Holy
Spirit that will lead us to repentance,
to obedience to the precepts of God, and
to embracing the righteousness of Christ
and the justification which comes
through faith and faith alone is my
prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Heat.
[Music]